groot is many things wise beyond his
words
adorable in his baby form and a true
team player and as seemingly evidenced
in avengers infinity war
groot is also as worthy as the god of
thunder himself to wield and his
guardian weapon
or so it seems infinity war code
directors joe and anthony russo have
finally revealed how groot was able to
lift thor's new weapon in the film
in avengers infinity war thor groot and
rocket traveled to nandavalier to meet
with etri
the asgardian dwarf and weapons forger
who created thor's fearsome
mjolnir the hammer that the norse god's
evil sister hella destroyed in thor
ragnarok
darling you have no idea what's possible
after sparking up a dying star and
reactivating the forge to channel its
raw energy the foursome craft thor's new
killer weapon the hammer meets battle
axe known as stormbreaker
the only thing missing from the weapon
is a handle groot steps up and
sacrifices one of his arms for the
purpose
causing every viewer to let out an awe
at his active bravery
and at the growing bond between the
blonde trust god and the tiny teen tree
but wait just a marvel minute if only
those who proved themselves worthy were
able to lift thor's old weapon mjolnir
how can groot pick up thor's shiny new
villain slaying toy stormbreaker
whosoever be he where they shall have it
the power
whatever man it's a trick does that mean
that groot is on an equal
playing field as thor in the eyes of the
asgardian spirits
as much as we love groot it turns out
that isn't the case
after a fan asked the russo brothers to
explain the scene wondering whether
groot was suddenly deemed worthy the
pair disclosed that groot was able to
lift stormbreaker because the weapon
doesn't have the same rules as mjolnir
the directors wrote on twitter mjolnir
requires worthiness
not stormbreaker there's actually a bit
of a catch when it comes to this
statement
sure anyone can pick up stormbreaker
regardless of predetermined suitability
but that doesn't mean it's easy to lift
the weapon
with mjolnir it was about both worth and
physical strength but it still wouldn't
budge unless someone deemed fit by the
asgardian gods tried to lift it no
matter how buffed they were
we need to go
with stormbreaker it's a different story
carrying such a special weapon is not
only a great responsibility
but it also requires great power and
let's remember that it isn't as though
groot lifted stormbreaker like it was a
piece of cosmic candy that had been
dropped on the ground
he was in a great deal of pain as he
wound his arm around the weapons two
parts before snapping it off to be used
as a handle
while he appears to be as physically
strong as thor at least from this
isolated incident groot isn't invincible
just because he can lift the same weapon
the norse god can
however groot's ability to hold
stormbreaker could
signal something much bigger than simply
how powerful the guardian is
there's a popular fan theory that
suggests groot who crumbled away into
space dust after thanos is calling at
the end of avengers infinity war
will come back to life in avengers 4
reborn through the wood
in stormbreaker groot sacrificed himself
in the first guardians of the galaxy
re-emerging after death as an infant
does that mean that he could perform
another self-resurrection in the
upcoming avengers movie
it might sound like a long shot to some
but joe russo who directs avengers 4
with his brother
anthony hasn't ruled it out completely
the filmmaker told huffington post
i don't know if every piece of him that
detaches can grow a future version of
him but who's to say
that's an interesting question
interesting enough to keep our minds
busy while we wait for avengers 4 to
drop
we think so oh
hey